now let's get to some of the audience
questions this one comes from
stephanie
stephanie highfill is their information
being recorded or being encoded into
less mainstream information media
channels that can be free that can be
parsed out john nash style like a
beautiful mind that could help us arrive
closer at the truth of this phenomenon
so i'm going to need your help kurt kind
of detangling that question because i'm
not familiar with the reference but when
you're saying encoded um
can can you repeat that question one
more time i want to answer it i just
want to make sure i'm understanding the
question okay just deciphering
essentially with somewhat of sufficient
intelligence can decipher that there are
different drops being
placed by let's say disclosure people
the government
oh oh i see what you're saying
breadcrumbs what i refer to as
breadcrumbs that one can decipher it
um
well you know i i've i've always left
breadcrumbs every interview i ever do
for the last four years
you know i think people can now go back
through a lot of what i've said in the
past and come back and say oh
so that's what he was referring to now
we know uh because certain people have
come out whether it's you know jim
mccaskey in his book or other folks
um
you know i i think
i can't speak on behalf of the
government and other people i suspect
that
um
what what i can say is i i think that we
are at a point now where
um we don't have to leave the
breadcrumbs
um
that that we have been in the past i
think i think the time has come for us
to be even a little bit more
straightforward and a little bit more
clear um
you know uh the difficult part is when
you're dealing with security clearances
and ndas which everybody hates to hear
you know that's that's becoming a
three-letter word um that i think is is
probably going to be etched somewhere on
my on my tombstone and people are going
to be throwing tomatoes at it you know
from here to eternity because they hate
it and they don't they don't but they
hate it because they don't really
understand what it means and why you
have them
um
you know those those ndas definitely get
in the way of having a complete
transparent conversation but i i also
think that that
we are having it i think where we were
we've come a long long ways
and as far as answering this specific
question as far as leaving breadcrumbs i
can't speak for anybody else i don't
know precisely what the gov because the
government isn't just this one
huge uh if you a monolithic enterprise
it's it's comprised of people and those
people each of those people have their
own interests and their own desires
and their own agendas and so i i can't
speak for them i can only speak for me
um
i think certainly if people were to look
at all the this talks i've given
uh and and really look at them and
listen to them closely they will see
that a a lot more has been said
than uh than might necessarily be
acknowledged